[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
تصعد بالعمق الروسي وبرلين تعتبر ضربات
اوكرانيا داخل روسيا مشروعه شرطه تنفيذها
باسلحه محليه
الازمه القادمه في اوروبا صربيا تتحرك
عسكريا وتدعو لحل سلمي والناتو يرسل قوات
الاضافيه
بعد اطلاقه حملته الانتخابيه لتمثيل
الجمهوريين بالانتخابات الرئاسيه الاعلام
الامريكي يصف حاكم فلوريدا بالنسخه الاكثر
تشددا من ترامب
وسيكون لدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
في اغرب احاطه لوكاله الطاقه الدوليه امام
مجلس الامن الحظ فقط وراء عدم وقوع كارثه
نوويه في
[موسيقى]
وبالحديث عن هجوم موسكو اقر الكرملين بان
الدفاعات الجويه بالعاصمه بحاجه الى تحسين
اما الحكومه الالمانيه فقد اعتبرت الضربات
الاوكرانيه داخل الاراضي الروسيه مشروعه
طالما يتم تنفيذها باسلحه محليه واوضح
المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه ان برلين
ترى انه وفقا للقانون الدولي فان هذه
الضربات مشروعه مشيرا الى ان المانيا
ستواصل تزويد كييف بالاسلحه بهدف الدفاع
عن اراضيها
[موسيقى]
فقد قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي
ان بلاده لا تريد تشجيع او تمكين الهجمات
الاوكرانيه مضيفا لا تملك معلومات عن هويه
مسؤول عن هجمات المسيرات على موسكو كما
تعهد المسؤول الامريكي بارسال منظومات
ستنجر المحموله وانظمه الدفاعيه لكنه اكد
ان ارسال طائرات اف 16 لاوكرانيا مرتبط
بضمان عدم استخدامها ضد روسيا
مع تزايد الهجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه
تقول صحيفه تايمز ان المجموعه التي تتبنى
الهجوم يقودها قومي روسي كان الكرملين شن
حمله قمع ضد المجموعات التي ينتمي اليها
بتهمه الارهاب والتامر على الكرملين
المزيد من التفاصيل في سياق التقرير الاتي
هذه المشاهد لن تكون الوحيده في موسكو بل
سيعتاد الروس على رؤيتها في قادم الايام
يقول هؤلاء او ما يعرف بفيلق روسيا الحره
مقاتلون روس تدعمهم
المجموعه التي باتت تظهر عقب كل هجوم داخل
الاراضي الروسيه تتوعد بتكثيف الضربات في
الداخل الروسي عقب اكتمال استعداداتها
فوفقا لقائد المجموعه المعروف باسم قيصر
فان الاف من المتطوعين ينتظرون الانضمام
الى مجموعته تحضيرا لمواصله هجماتهم ضد
اهداف داخل روسيا بما فيها العاصمه موسكو
يقول الرجل ان وحدته بقوه كتيبه والتي
عاده ما تتكون من 500 الى 1000 جندي
ولديهم خطط للتوسع على الارض واخرى لزياده
القوات من اجل القيام بما سماه حمله
الكرملين
ترفض المجموعه وصفها بالعصابه او شركه
عسكريه مثل فاجنر بل كونهم معارضه روسيه
مسلحه تريد تحرير بلدها كما تقول تقول
المجموعه انها تقف وراء الهجوم الاخيره
على موسكو بالطائرات المسيره والهدف منه
هو دعمه هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد وبمثابه حمل
التجنيد لتشجيع الروس على الاطاحه
وفقا لصحيفه التايمز فان قائد المجموعه
قومي روسي وكان عضوا في مجموعتين يمينيتين
تم تصنيفهما كمنظمات ارهابيه بتهمه التامر
ضد الكرملين وان الاخيره شن حمله قمع ضد
الحركه القوميه منذ اكثر من عقد في محاوله
لوقف شعبياتها المتزايده التي يرجح ان
بوتين كان ينظر اليها على انها تهديد
محتمل لحكمه تهديد يبدو انه عاد للظهور
مجددا وبشكل
مختلف
من موسكو جبر مدير مكتب جريده شرق الاوسط
في موسكو اهلا بك معنا استاذ رائد في
العربيه 360 الى اي مدى تشكل هذه المجموعه
خطوره حقيقيه على روسيا على روسيا الرسميه
والكراملين وعلى الرئيس الروسي وماذا لو
تلقى الدعما من الغرب
نعم مساء الخير بالفعل هو سؤال ملح الان
هذه المجموعه حتى الان لا يمكن الحديث عن
انها تشكل خطر جدي لا يوجد معطيات كثيره
حول تعدادها مثلا اعداد المتطوعين الذين
يمكن ان ينضموا
اليهم ولكن حتى الان التحركات التي قامت
بها لا تشكل خطرا جديا بقدر ما هي تشكل
خطر معنوي ورمزي
يعني
دعايتهم روايته منذ بدايه الحرب على انه
يواجه النازيين في اوكرانيا الان
وهو ذهب الى اوكرينه للدفاع عن الروس كما
ن
ذكر يعني عدد الصعيد الداخلي هذا امر يعني
سوف يهز بعض الشيء الروايه الروسيه ولكن
الاخطر من ذلك يعني كما ذكرت في جزء من
سؤالك
اتلقى دعما غربيا واسعا الان نحن نتحدث عن
مجموعه من المتطوعين
عشرات الطائرات المسيره هذا امر ليس سهلا
وهناك اجهزه استخبارات تنظم عملها وتوجهه
اذا نحن امام ربما تطور
سيؤدي بطبيعه الحال الى يعني زياده
الاعباء على وتحويلها الى عبء داخلي ايضا
بعد ان كان خلال خمس
شهرا الماضيه من الحرب مرتاحا الى حد بعيد
تمام ساعود اليك بموضوع متعلق بالسلام هذه
المره اكثر منه بالحرب ولكن بعد ان نشير
الى تخطيط اوكرانيا وحلفائها لعقد قمه على
مستوى زعماء العالم لكن مع استثنائي روسيا
بهدف حشد الدعم لانهاء الحرب وفقا لشروط
كياف حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
نقلا عن مستشار رئاسي اوكراني رفيع
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين
طبقا لويل جورنال في القمه المقترحه تحظى
بدعم قوي من القاده الاوروبيين بمن فيهم
الرئيس الفرنسي مسؤولون اوروبيون قالوا
انهم يعملون مع كييف لاعاده صياغه خطه
السلام الاوكرانيه بطرق تجعلها اكثر قبولا
للقوى العالميه كبير موظفي الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه اندرير ماك قال ان المفاوضات
المباشره مع روسيا ليست ممكنه طالما بقيت
قواتها في اوكرانيا الرئيس الاوكراني
خطه من عشر نقاط وناقشها مع نظيره
الاميركي جو بايدن من النقاط المطروحه
استعاده سيطره اوكرانيا على اراضيها هو
اعاده الاسرى ومحاكمه جرائم الحرب اضافه
لضمان الامن الغذائي من خلال حمايه صادرات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
التوقعات تشير الى ان القمه ربما تعقد قبل
الاجتماع المزمع لقاده دول النيتو في
يوليو المقبل في ليتوانيا بحسب جورنال
فكره القمه تبلورت خلال محادثه بين
الرئيسين الاوكراني والفرنسي في فبراير مع
ضغط الاخير على كييف لقبول فكره انه لابد
من محادثات سلام مع الكرملين بنهايه
المطاف
استاذ رائد كيف يمكن ان نترجم هذا الكلام
من حيث الموقف الروسي
اسيه الاميه بالدرجه الاولى يعني شاهدنا
اهم من ذلك شاهدنا شبع اجماع في مثلا
الهيئه العامه للامم المتحده
وانه كانت روسيا تقريبا مع عدد محدود من
البلدان معزوله
والغالبيه العظمى من الدول يعني ايدت
الموقف نشهد في قمه من هذا النوع يعني
اعتقد انه
هذه خطوه اقل يمكن ان ترى الامور من هنا
من موسكو انه لن يكون لها تاثير كبير لا
قرارات ملزمه ولا موقف واضح العالم منقسم
الى حد بعيد صحيح هناك عزله
لكن كل افريقيا مثلا على الحياد المنطقه
العربيه كلها الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
كله على الحياد امريكا اللاتينيه بالنسبه
لموسكو هذه المواقف هي المهمه وانه لا
يمكن ان يحصد الغرب يحشد الغرب اجماعا
حقيقيا ومؤثرا يمكن ان يفضي يعني الى
قرارات ملزمه بشكل او باخر شكرا جزيلا لك
استاذ رائد جابر مدير مكتب جريده الشرق
الاوسط في موسكو تحياتي اليك
ولا نعود الى الملف الاوكراني في هذه
النشره وتحديدا الى الوضع في محطه النوويه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ايضا في العربيه 360 وكاله
الطاقه اغلق ملف موقع نووي ايراني سري بعد
الحصول على اجابات من طهران وتتهمها
بمواصله انتهاك قيود برنامجها النوويه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عبر وزير الدفاع الصربيه
ميلود خلال زيارته للجيش الصربي بالقرب من
الحدود مع كوسوفو عبر عن امله في ايجاد حل
سياسي سلمي في كوسوفو لكن دون المساس
بقدره بلاده على الدفاع عن سيادتها
هذه هي الرساله الاكثر اهميه لمواطن
جمهوريه صربيا انها الامل في الحفاظ على
السلام والاستقرار لكن دون المساس بقدره
على الدفاع عن سياده جمهوريه صربيا وجميع
مواطنيها نفذت القوات المسلحه الصربيه
واعضاء وزاره الشؤون الداخليه بنجاح جميع
المهام الموكله اليهم من قبل الدوله حيث
يتعين علينا بذل كل جهد لايجاد حل سياسي
سلمي هذه هي الرساله الاهم للمواطنين
اذا التوتر يتواصل في كوسوفو بين الاقليه
الصربيه في الشمال والحكومه المركزيه منذ
ان بدات الاشتباكات يوم الجمعه ما لا يقل
عن 30 جنديا من قوات حفظ السلام التابعه
للنيتو اصيبوا في الاشتباكات وهم 19 جنديا
ايطاليا واحد عشر جنديا مجريا على اثر ذلك
اعلن الامين العام
700 جندي اضافي لمهمه حفظ السلام اضافه
الى ثلاثه الاف وثمانمائه جندي اعلى الارض
نعود لاصل الحكايه عقدتك انتخابات بلديه
في ابريل الماضي ونسبه المشاركه فيها لم
تتجاوز ثلاثه ونصف في المئه ثلاثه ونصفا
في المئه صرب كوسوفو الذين لا يعترفون
بسلطه الحكومه المركزيه قاطعوا الانتخابات
ليتم انتخاب رؤساء بلديه البان في مناطق
ذات غالبيه صربيه
شراره الاشتباكات كانت عندما سلمت الحكومه
اعضاء مجالس البلديات الذين انتخبوا
مهامهم رسميا مع تجاهل الرئيس الوزراء
البن كورتي الدعوات للتهدئه وارسلت
الحكومه المركزيه قوات امن مدججه بالسلاح
للسيطره على مباني احد البلديات شمال
البلاد او احدى البلديات هناك ما اعاد
اشعال الاوضاع المتوتره منذ عقود ننتقل
للخريطه الان وهنا يمكن ان نجد المقاطعات
ذات الغالبيه الصربيه والمحاذيه للحدود مع
صربيا اذا نتحدث عن المحافظات او المناطق
الشماليه بشكل اساسي نتحدث عن
زوبين بوتوك
وغيرها من وغيرهما من المناطق الشماليه
المحاذيه للحدود الاشتباكات تركزت فيتشان
التي تجمع بل
محتاجون صرب امام بلديتها مطالبين بسحب
رؤساء البلديات الالبان من الذين فازوا في
الانتخابات المحليه وكذلك سحب قوات شرطه
على الجانب الاخر من الحدود اعلن رئيس
صربيا الكزان وضع الجيش في حاله تاهب قسوه
تحسبا لاي تطورات الا ان للازمه ابعادا
اقليميه ودوليه طبعا هاله ردود الافعال
بالامس واليوم ففيما وجه الغرب اتهامات
لروسيا بدفع الصرب نحو التصعيد في كوسوفو
من اجل الضغط على اوروبا وربما ابعاد
انظارها عن اوكرانيا اتت موسكو لتقول من
جانبها وهي الحديثه التاريخيه لصربيا
لتقول للغرب او لتدعو الغرب الى وقف ما
وصفته بالدعايه الكاذبه بشان الاحداث فيك
[موسيقى]
اننا نراقب الوضع وندعم صربيا وسربه بشكل
مطلق وغير مشروط نعتقد انه يجب احترام
جميع الحقوق والمصالح المشروعه لسرب
كوسوفو وضمانها ولا ينبغي ان يكون هناك
مكان لنوع من الاعمال الاستفزازيه التي
تنتهك حقوق الصرب بالطبع نتابع التطورات
عن كسب وقلقون بشان ذلك
من جانبه قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل
ماكرون ان سلطات كوسوفو تتحمل مسؤوليه
الاضطرابات التي تصاعدت منذ تولي رؤساء
البلديات المنحدرين من اصل الباني مهامهم
في المنطقه ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه شمال
البلاد
من هذا النوع سالتقي مع المستشار الالماني
اولافشولت ورئيسي كوسوفو وصربيا كما فعلنا
في اجتماع براك لكن من الواضح جدا ان
السلطات الكوسوفيه تتحمل بعض المسؤوليه عن
الوضع الحالي وكان هناك عدم احترام لاتفاق
مهم تم التوقيع عليه قبل اسبوعين فقط
معنا من كوسوفو صحفي محمد
مدير المعهد الوطني للامن الدولي اهلا بكم
معنا كذلك اهلا بكما اذا ابدا معك استاذ
محمد من لماذا
قامت كوسوفو بما يعتبر من الجانب الصربي
تصعيدا بتسليم هؤلاء الرؤساء رؤساء
البلديات مهامهم رغبه المشاركه المتدنيه
جدا في الانتخابات ورغم عدم مراعاه كل
عوامل التمييزيه التي قد تؤدي الى تصعيد
كبير على الارض اخذين بعين الاعتبار
انحدارهم يعني انهم البان في في مناطق صرب
تحيه لك في سوريا وتحيه لجميع المشاهدين
لقناه العربيه
اعلنت الاستقلال لسنه 2008
لكن الاقليه الصربيه في تلك المناطق وليست
الاقليه صربيا ولكن بعض المجموعات
الاجراميه التي نحن نسميها او التي تسميها
الحكومه الكوسفيه هي التي تسعى
لزعزعه الاستقرار
من خلال هذه المناطق او هذه البلد حتى
السلطات الصربيه تحاول منذ ان استقلت
كوسوفا ان تسبب
اضطرابات وتسبب مشاكل لكوسفات ودائما بهدف
ان هدفه الاساسي لصربيا هي ليست حمايه
مصالح الصرف في كوسوفا لكن هي بهدف
كسر بعض المصالح السياسيه لها وهي التي
خاصه يعني حتى حلفائكم الامريكان وزير
الخارجيه يقول انه قرار البن كورتي
ادى الى زياده التوتر بشكل كبير وغير
ضروري
يعني حتى الحلفائكم مش فهمانين هذا الموقف
يعني لماذا فرنسا ايضا يعني اشرنا الى
موقفها قبل قبل قليل وساعود من الجانب
الاخر الى ضيفنا في الجهه المقابله ولكن
اجبني عن هذه النقطه لو سمحت
تقريبا مشكله او
المشاكل في هذه المناطق الشمال الكوسا هي
ليست وليده الان ولكن هي منذ انتهاء
انتهاء الحرب او منذ 25 سنه
الاوروبيون والحلفاءنا الغرب ديون الى
الان ما استطع ان يجدوا الحل لهذه المشكله
يبدو ان الوضع الحالي او
بسبب العلاقات التاريخيه بين صربيا وروسيا
المستمر الغربي او الدول الغربيه الحديثه
لكوسفا تسعى الان جاهزا لاستماله صربيا
الى حلفها او معادها عن روسيا فلهذا السبب
هي تقدم تنازلات لها واحده تلو الاخرى
خليني اشوف دكتور اذا سمحت لي دكتور داركو
ضيفنا من كوسوفو يقول ان مجموعات اجراميه
هي التي يعني
تتسبب بزعزعه الامن والاستقرار في تلك
المناطق
وبالتالي يعني ليس الموضوع موضوع انتخابات
ورئاسات بلديات
من قبل الالبان في مناطق صربيه ما رايك
تحياتي لكم في الاستوديو والى زميلي
العزيز الذي تفضل بالاجابه قبل الوضع معقد
للغايه
فهناك مشاكل وتدعيه سياسيه التي لا يمكن
حلها بطريقه تتجلى بارسال قوات خاصه
لكنك محق فيما ذهبت اليه بان هناك
ايضا روسيه قد تكون لها علاقه
فسيد الكورتي
الذي
تاثر
بالسياسه الروسيه التي سادت هناك لفتره ان
البانيا كانت في ظل الشيوعيه لمده خمسين
سنه وفي عهده الاتحاد الاتحاد السوفيتي
سابق وهؤلاء المجرمون الذين نراهم الان في
بعض المناطق
من الواضح ان ان اصابع روسيه
موجوده هناك وقد تكون هي المسؤوله عن كل
ما يحدث ونعلم ان
المواطنين من دوري الاصول الالبانيه
مثل ادوات بيد الروس لكن لكن العالم برمته
حتى السيد بلينكل كانوا
قد عملوا على ارسال قوات الخاصه لحل
المشكله وهذا امر غير مقبول
روسيا تقول على لسان الكرملين بانه هي
تدعم السكان الصرب في كوسوفو وتؤمن بضروره
حمايه حقوقهم القانونيه
وبحمايه مصالحهم وانه هذه الازمه تتابعها
باهتمام خاصه بعد الانتخابات الان اذا
روسيا هي المتهمه بمحاوله تغذيه هذه
النزعه الصربيه عند حلفائها الصرب من اجل
افتعال مشكله يعني تلهي الغرب عن اوكرانيا
كيف تقرا هذا العنوان ايضا
كما اسلفت الحديث ليس
صربيا بل ايضا هي تعمل على تغذيه الالبان
وحتى السيد
البن كرسي وولده ادم كان الشخص الذي
تشرب من السياسه الروسيه
والسياسه اللينيه الماركسيه في السابق لذا
اتخيلوا انا عدت عليك نفس السؤال لانه ما
فهمتش الاجابه الاولى في الواقع انت تقول
بان روسيا تدعم الالبان روسيا تدعم الصلب
وحليف تاريخي لهم والان تقول بانه هي
لتدعم الالبان هو متاثر بالروس وهو يعني
انت تقول انا متاثر بالروس ويعمل ضد
الرغبات الروسيه ومن ثم روسيا تعلن موقفها
داعمه للصرب من جديد كيف فسر لنا لو سمحت
قد عرف انه من الجهه
المتطرفه
اليمنيه وبعد ذلك كان في السابق في الحزب
اليساري المتطرف ومن ثم انتقل الى حزب
اليمني
المتطرف
ولعلكم تتذكرون في التاريخ ان البانيا
بلاد شيوعيه محضه تحت تاثير روسيا والصين
في العالم والان ولهذا السبب فان السيد
بوتين لا السيت بارتنر لم يقل لشركاء في
الغرب او غيرهم عن نواياهي
وعلى هذا الاساس يمكننا ان نرى ايضا بين
الصرب
ترون هناك الاصابع الروسيه التي لها دور
طيب خلينا نحاول نفهم الموضوع منعدل دكتور
داركو لو سمحت يعني نفهم الموضوع ايضا رد
فعلك او قراءتك لما قاله سيد او دكتور
داركو استاذ محمد كالسي تفضل
صراحه الذي قال زميلي داركو من بلغراد لا
اساس لها من الصحه هذا شيء من الخيال يعني
الدوله الوحيده في المنطقه التي لم تفرض
عقوبات على روسيا هي صربيا والدوله
الوحيده في المنطقه لديها القاعده
العسكريه بالمسميات اخرى
الاغافيه هي روسيا وصربيا هي المعروفه ان
الحليف الوحيد في اوروبا اليوم كله
لروسيا هي صربيا
صراحه لن اقول رجل
ينتمي الى حزب يساري لكن هو الوطن
وحاليا الشعب الوحيد الذي في المنطقه الذي
هو الحليفه الاستراتيجي للغرب وكذلك
للولايات المتحده هم الالبان هو شعب
الالباني سواء في البانيا او في قصفه واصل
قصفه تم تحريرها من
بمساعده حلف الناتو سنه 1999 كما هو
المعروف السلطات القمعيه التي كانت في
كوسفه اثناء العهد الرئيس ميلوشي الذي حكم
بجرائم الحرب في لوهايت وهو الشيء المعروف
يعني
القصبه ما تسعى لدينا هناك في كوسفا كذلك
البلديه الاخرى
ليس فقط في شمال كوسفا ذات اغلبيه سكانيه
صربيا لكن هم يعيشون
متكامل مال البان هنا وليست عندهم اي
مشاكل هذا في شمال يتم استغلالها
والتوظيفها كل ما تكون مشاكل هناك في
صربيا صربيا من خلال بعض العصابات
الاجراميه المنظمه
تدخلها وتسبب مشاكل ونحن راينا حتى في
المظاهرات
قبل يومين او ثلاثه ايام يعني هناك تم
الضبط عناصر
من الشرطه السلبيه داخل الصربيه الذين
شاركوا عندنا في هذه المظاهرات ناخذ تعليق
اخير باختصار لو سمحت دكتور داركو باختصار
لو سمحت تعليقك ردك على ما تفضل به استاذ
محمد
[موسيقى]
بكل تاكيد نعم
ليست بلد مستقل وليست عضو في الامم
المتحده ودول كثيره لم تعترف بكتبه
وباستقلالها ودول خمس في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي النيتو
لها وجهه النظر هذه هي الحقيقه والصرب
تدعي بانها جزء من اراضيها
ارى انها مشكله سياسيه كبيره يجدر حلها
بما يعود بالنفع للشعبين وبما يعود لمصلحه
الاقليات التي تعيش هناك هذه مساله يجب ان
تجد ارضيه مشتركه
يمكن ان نتخيل انفو سوف تصبح دوله في
الامم متت في عضو في الامم المتحده
لابد لنا ان نجد حلا سياسيا لكن لا يمكن
لضيفكم السيد محمد ان لم اذكر الحقائق
وارى العكس تماما لان ما اراه هو وتحدثت
عنها عنه هو انه ادله
فسيد البنفورتي ينتمي الى تلك المدرسه
اليونانيه المراكيه وانت قد تكون محق بانه
بانه شريك مع الولايات المتحده لكن اود ان
اذكركم ان السيد بلينك قد ذكر بان السيد
كرسي هو المسؤول لذا تمت خطا ما الامل ان
تتفق معي في وجهه النظر تلك
شكله موضوع سيطول ولنا لقاءات اخرى ان شاء
الله شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
داركوفيتش مدير المعهد الامن الوطني او
مدير المعهد الوطني للامن في بلغراد من
كوسوفو صحفيه محمد
[موسيقى]
قالت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في
تقرير دوري ان ايران تواصل انتهاك القيود
المفروضه على برنامجها النووي واكدت
الوكاله ان طهران سمحت لها بتركيب اجهزه
مراقبه بموقعين معلنين للتخصيب وهي
بانتظار التعاون الايراني لتركيب كاميرات
مراقبه بجميع المواقع النوويه واشارت
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الى انه لم يعد
لديها اسئله بشان وجود اثار لليورانيوم في
احد المواقع وذلك بعد ان قدمت طهران شرحا
بهذا الصدد الا ان التقرير اكد ان مخزون
ايران من اليورانيوم يتجاوز 23 مره الحد
المسموح لها
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث اندلعت اشتباكات في
مدينتي الخرطوم واندرمان وجاء ذلك بعد
اعلان الجيش تعليق مشاركته في مفاوضات
الهدنه في جده دون الانسحاب منها وحمل
الجيش قوات الدعم السريع المسؤوليه حيث
قال انها لم تلتزم بالهدنه المعلنه
هذا ووصف المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي في البيت الابيض جون كربي انسحاب
احد اطراف الصراع في السودان من المفاوضات
مفاوضات الهدنه بالامر المؤسف واضاف كيربي
ان القتال في السودان بين الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع يجب ان يتوقف وان تصل
المساعدات
قال القائد الثاني لقوات الدعم السريع عبد
الرحيم دجالو قال ان قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلوح متي بخير ويقاتل
مع قواته في الصفوف الاولى على الارض
الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في الصفوف
الاماميه مع قواته والانسان
[موسيقى]
قالت وسائل اعلام تونسيه ان قاضي التحقيق
بخطب مكافحه الارهاب بدات تحقيقا يشمل
زعماء احزاب سياسيه ورؤساء حكومات
ومسؤولين امنيين سابقين بتهمه التامر على
امن الدوله التحقيق يشمل اساسا زعيم حركه
النهضه راشد الغنوشي والقيادي في الحركه
ورئيس الحكومه الاسبق علي العريض ورئيس
الحكومه الاسبق يوسف الشاهد ومدير الديوان
رئيس الجمهوريه السابقه ناديه عكاشه
والوزير القيادي السابق في حركه النهضه
لطفي زيتون وفق وسائل الاعلام التونسيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ايضا رغم التحذيرات من مخاطر
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن فوائده جنه نستعرض
بعضها بعد الفصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دعا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينك تركيا الى
الموافقه على انضمام السويد الى حلف
النيتو مشيرا الى ان السويد اتخذت بالفعل
خطوات المهمه لمعالجه اعتراضات انقره على
عضويتها
نحو تركيا والمجر اللتين لم تصادق بعد على
الانضمام على فعل ذلك في اسرع وقت ممكن لا
يوجد سبب لمزيد من الوقت السويد جاهزتنا
الان هذا القرار يجب ان يمضي قدما الان
اعتقد ان تركيا اثرت الانتباه الى بعض
مخاوفها الامنيه وان السويد وفنلندا اتخذت
خطوات ملحوظه لمعالجتها لقد اثبتت السويد
مرارا وتكرارا التزامها بحلف الناتو
يصوت مجلس النواب الامريكي بعد قليل على
مشروع قانون سقف الدين وبحسب عضو المجلس
فانه سيتم اقراره الاتفاق اليوم وكانت
لجنه القواعد بمجلس النواب قد اقرت امس
تشريع سقف الدين الذي توصل اليه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيس المجلس النواب
كافن مقارتي في وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع
ويقضي التشريع بتعليق سقف الدين حتى الاول
من يناير من عام 2025 ما سيسمح للرئيس
الامريكي والمشرعين بتاجييل هذا الملف الى
ما بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه في نوفمبر من
العام المقبل وفي حال اقر مجلس النواب
الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون مشروع القانون
فسيحيله الى مجلس الشيوخ لبحثه والتصويت
عليه قبل احالته للرئيس بايدن للتوقيع
عليه
حضرت فوكس نيوز الامريكيه من حمله اعلاميه
ممنهجه تهدف لعرقله المرشح راندي سانتوس
واظهاره على انه خطر على الحريه الفكريه
والاكاديميه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
يبدو ان الصعود الصاروخي لشعبيه
رونديسانتوس منافسه ترامب على قياده الحزب
الجمهوري قد اربكت الديمقراطيين مثل ما
اربكت ترامب
تحذر من حمله اعلاميه مسبقه تشنها وسائل
اعلام تحاول عرقله ديسانس باشاعه انه اكثر
خطرا على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه من منافس
هترامب مستدله بعدد من المقابلات
والتغريدات التي برزت مؤخرا من صحفيين
ديمقراطيين بعد
سيتان
صحف مقربه من الجمهوريين تصف ديسانتوس
بانه مستقبل الحزب الشاب الاكثر نجاحا
وشعبيه في البلاد وخير وريث للترامبيه
القويه فيما يحذر ديموقراطيون بان افكار
ديسانس المتجدده تهدد الحريه الفكريه
والاك
وتنمي قوه التطرف ما قد يدفع البلاد لحرب
اهليه
عوده امريكا العظمى تبدا باعاده الى قوي
منزله بلدنا يسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ لقد
انهارت حدودنا الجنوبيه ملايين المهاجرين
غير الشرعيين والمجرمين على قوائم الارهاب
يدخلون الاف الضحايا من المخدرات وانظروا
الى الاقتصاد اداره بايدن تفعل كل ما في
وسعها لجعل الحياه اكثر صعوبه للاسر
العاديه
وديسانتوس سبق وان تحدث عن ميله لاتخاذ
تشريعات صارمه ضد عدد من القضايا التي
يعتبرها الديمقراطيون حريه مثل قضايا
الضرائب والاجهاض والمهاجرين والتعليم
وحمل السلاح
[موسيقى]
الحظ والحظ فقط هو الذي يمنع وقوعا انفجار
نووي في محطه باوكرانيا لكن تجنب حادث
نووي ممكن وفق مبادئ اعلنها المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافاييل
طلب بعدم شن هجوم مهما كان نوعه من المحطه
او عليها وبعدم استخدام الموقع لتخزين
اسلحه او عسكريين او عدم فصلها عن شبكه
الكهرباء المحليه محطه النوويه هي الاكبر
في اوروبا وتعرضت سابقا لعمليات استهداف
بشكل متكرر وقطعها عن شبكه الكهرباء سبعه
مرات تم منذ استيلاء الجيش الروسي عليها
بعد ايام من بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
مبادئ الوكاله الدوليه حظيت بتوافق
اوكراني روسي خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن
الدولي السفير الروسيه فاسيلين قال ان
مقترحات جروس تتماشى مع الاجراءات الروسيه
القائمه بالفعل المحطه معتبرا ان اي تهديد
للمحطه هو من كياف والغرب بالمقابل قال
السفير الاوكرانيه
ان مبادئ المدير العام لضمان سلامه محطه
زابوريا تنطبق على جميع محطات توليد
الطاقه في العالم داعيا لنزع السلاح من
المنطقه وانهاء ما وصفه بالاحتلال الروسي
للمحطه المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايا الجروس يعتبر ان
الاهم هو الحد الادنى المشترك والذي قال
انه حظي بتاييد واسع النطاق ولم يعارضه اي
صوت قام بزياره المحطه نهايه مارس الماضي
وهو يكفر منذ ذلك الحين جهوده محذرا من
خطر حقيقي لوقوع حادث نووي الى ذلك قالت
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان اوكرانيا عطلت
جميع مبادرات المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لتعزيز سلامه محطه
زابوريجيا واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان
موسكو لا تعتزم نشر وحدات او اعتاد عسكري
في محطه ذا فورجيه للطاقه نوويه للمشاركه
في عمليات قتاليه
معنا من القاهره دكتور علي اسلام رئيس
هيئه الطاقه الذريه المصريه سابقا اهلا بك
معنا الدكتور يعني هل توافق على تعبير
جروسسي بان الحظ فقط هو الذي منع وقوع
حادث النووي في زابوريجيا المحطه النوويه
في اوكرانيا
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك
وللساده المشاهدين انا بقول طبعا موافق
جدا على هذا التحليل لانه من المؤكد كما
يعني
قلت سابقا مرارا ان المحطه النوويه غير
مهيئه لان يكون حولها نزاع عسكري
فطبعا في ظل تصاعد العمليات العسكريه حول
محطه اللي هي تعتبر اكبر محطه نوويه بها
ست مفاعلات اكبر محطه النوويه في اوروبا
فيها ست وحدات طبعا ده يمثل خطوره كبيره
جدا
اذا سمحت لي يعني استهدافها مباشره او
استخدام الموقع للتخزين اسلحه وعسكريين او
فصله عن شبكه الكهرباء يعني كل معظم او
اهم المبادئ اللي وضعها بالامس
ما اخطر ما عليها
هو الحقيقه هو مستر جروسي وضع من اكثر من
سنه تقريبا
سبع مبادئ يعني يعني ممكن تلخيصها وهي
فعلا المبادئ دي اللي بيتكلم عليها ان هو
الان من انه عدم تنفيذ هذه المبادئ انت
سيادتك تذكر انه من سنه كان في طبعا برضو
عمليات حوالين صحيح وكان في بعثه من هيئه
من وكاله الدوليه الطاقه الذريه ظهرت هذا
صحيح روسيا يعني غير قادره على ضمان عدم
استهدافها وعلى ضمان ان لا يحدث يعني حادث
نووي كبير في في تلك المحطه
اليست هي من المتضررين الاكبر ممن يمكن ان
يتضرروا من هكذا حادث دكتور
هو طبعا هو طبعا الضرر من وقوع حادث
نتيجه مخالفه السبع مبادئ دول
طبعا هيكون خطر على
الاوكرانيا وروسيا بل والعالم كله فهو
اللي بيقول انه فعلا الحظ فقط حالفنا في
انه ما يحصلش حادث وخاصه في حاجتين ان هو
قلقان جدا كمان من ناحيه
في يعني من امس قلقان جدا من انه في البلد
القريبه من
زابولوجيا ابتدا
الناس تتهجر منها معنى ذلك ان هو متوقع
انه فيه نزاعي يشتد
النتري وانه العدد اللي موجود حاليا في
محطه زابولوجيا
يصلح العادي
او
في حاله
الطبيعيه ولكن ما ماذا عن صيانه المفاعل
وصيانه
[موسيقى]
القطعه الغيار اللازمه دي كلها مسائل
لا تخطا
لان يكون في حرب حواليها لانه بيقول انه
المفروض انه يبقى في دايما
وسائل الامداد بقطع الغيار ووسائل الامداد
للتيار دائما تكون موجوده هو كان دايما
المحطه سابقا كان لها اربع
وسائل
للتغذيه الكهربائيه من اربع مصادر مختلفه
حاليا مفيش فقط الا مصدر واحد اللي هو 750
كيلو فولت من
السيرمال
يبقى طبعا العامل الاساسي هو التعاون يعني
بين وكاله الدوليه التقديريه وروسيا انتم
على اكمل وجه من اجل حمايه العالم كله من
حادث نووي محتمل في تلك المحطه شكرا دائما
لوجودك معنا
ولمرافقتنا في شرح هذا الموضوع الحساس جدا
دكتور علي اسلام رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه
المصريه سابقا من القاهره ونتوجه مباشره
الى الامريكي
وتتواصل عمليه التصويت هناك على مشروع
قانون سقف الدين وهذه العمليه ستستمر
لساعات طبعا نقاش مستفيد حصل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حول هذا الموضوع ومن
المقرر انه يعني يمر مشروع القانون ومن ثم
بعد مجلس النواب يذهب الى مجلس الشيوخ
مجلس شيوخ انطلب تعديلات يعود الى مجلس
النواب ليجريها وان لم يطلب تعديلات يرفع
الى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لكي يوقعوا
ونحن نبقي عينا على هذا الموضوع في حال
ورود اي جديد
[موسيقى]
خلال الايام الماضيه بدا الحديث عن اخطار
الذكاء الاصطناعي الا انه جزء من كل
مجالات الحياه اليوميه وربما نستخدمه دون
ان ندرك ذلك هذه بعض من المجالات التي
تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي نتابع
مجالات للذكاء الاصطناعي من الامثله على
المجالات التي يتم استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي فيها
الطب حيث ترى تطور كبير في القطاع الصحي
من خلال الجراحات التي يتم فيها استخدام
روبوتات تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي
الامن السيبراني وفيه تستخدم انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي للتعرف على الهجمات الالكترونيه
والتهديدات الاخرى
التسوق الالكتروني
وفيه يتم توفير توصيات شخصيه للناس بناء
على امثله سابقه لبحثهم وعمليات الشراء
البحث عبر الانترنت اذ ان محرك البحث
يعتمد على مدخلات كبيره من البيانات
لتقديم نتائج البحث المطلوبه
المساعد الرقمي المساعدون الرقميون كما هو
الحال في الهواتف الذكيه التي توفر خدمات
المساعده للاجابه على الاسئله او تنظيم
الروتين اليومي
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من باكستان
وعمران خان تحديدا رئيس وزراء البلاد
السابق وهو يخرج من محكمه اسلام اباد
العليا لكنه غير ظاهر بالصوره لانه محاط
بالعديد من افراد الامن المحكمه مددت
الافراج بكفاله عن عمران خان لثلاثه ايام
في عده قضايا مرفوعه ضده لكن وزير
الداخليه الباكستاني قال انه سيحاكم امام
محكمه عسكريه عمران خان يواجهتها من منها
الفساد والارهاب وسوء استخدام السلطه لكنه
ينفي هذه التهم ويعتبرها ملفقه وذات دوافع
سياسيه
لكل امرئ من اسمه نصيب وبشرى اكبر دليل
جلبت البشرى لمئات المرضى غير القادرين
على تحمل تكلفه العلاج بشرى طبيبه في
منطقه المينا في طرابلس بلبنان تعالج
المرضى برسوم رمزيه وتقدم ادويه مجانيه
لهم لم تمنعها سنواتها السبع والستين او
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه المتدهوره في لبنان من
تقديم الاستشاره المجانيه لمرضاها حتى
لقبت بام الفقراء
نهايه العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع تتابع فيها الزميله ميسون بعد قليل
في اخبار الساعه ايضا ميسون اهلا بك ماذا
لديك الليله مساء الخير طاهر مجددا قائد
فاجنر يساعد تجاه القاده العسكريين الروس
ايضا لدينا التصعيد بين كوسوفو وصربيا
وايضا التصعيد بين طالبان افغانستان
وايران بالاضافه ايضا لموضوع البيت الابيض
الذي اسف لخروج الجيش السوداني من
المفاوضات طبعا هناك العديد ايضا من
الاخبار نامل ان تتابعنا ان شاء الله
تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات